وزير الخارجية توني بلينكين
يخرج بأقوى تصريحاته
حتى الآن في حث إسرائيل على بذل المزيد من الجهد لحماية
المدنيين في غزة. وافقت إسرائيل على
وقفتين صغيرتين للنوافذ كل يوم
حتى يتمكن المدنيون من الخروج من
منطقة القتال في شمال غزة. اليوم ينتهي بعد
دقائق فقط.  قبل لينكولن على الرغم من
توضيح أن الإدارة لا تعتقد أن
هذا
يكفي، هناك الكثير مما يجب القيام به أه
لحماية المدنيين وأه التأكد
من وصول النظام الإنساني إليهم، لقد
قُتل عدد كبير جدًا من الفلسطينيين،
وقد عانى الكثير أه
في الماضي
قال بلينكين هذا قبل أسابيع، في الوقت الذي
شوهدت فيه المزيد من الانفجارات هذه المرة
بالقرب من اثنين من مستشفيات غزة، حيث
تقول إسرائيل إن حماس وضعت بعض
مقارها
تحت حجم الأضرار
غير المعروفة هناك، لكن كلا المستشفيين
أفادا أنهما ما زالا يعملان
ويعالجان المرضى.  لديك مقطع فيديو جديد
يظهر
آثار قصف أحد الوالدين بالقرب من
مستشفى ثالث، مستشفى ألفا في
شمال غزة، يمكنك رؤية أشخاص ملطخين
بالدماء ويطلبون المساعدة في
الفناء في أعقاب ذلك، هذا
هو المستشفى الآن  يأوي العديد من
الأشخاص الذين يبحثون عن غطاء ومستشفى رابع،
هذا المستشفى للأطفال،
محاط بالدبابات التي يطلب
مدير المستشفى الآن المساعدة في
إجلاء الأطباء والصبر هناك،
دعنا ننتقل إلى قناة CNN أو أورين ليبرمان
للانضمام إلينا من تل أبيب أورين، دعنا نتحدث
أولاً عن  تعليقات الوزير
بلينكن اليوم ما هو
التأثير المحتمل لهذه
الكلمات، حسنًا، سنرى ما إذا كانت ستجبر
القيادة الإسرائيلية والجيش الإسرائيلي على تغيير
طريقة عملهما، ولكن حتى الآن
لا توجد بالتأكيد مؤشرات على ذلك على
أرض الواقع مع الجيش الإسرائيلي  قائلين إنهم
حاصروا مدينة غزة ويمكننا أن
نرى بوضوح من مقاطع الفيديو هذه أن جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي يتحرك بشكل
أعمق وأعمق في قلب
مدن غزة، بما في ذلك وفقًا
لقادة المستشفيات هناك المحيطة ببعض
المستشفيات مع وقوع غارات
على مقربة جدًا من
المسؤولين الذين أثروا على تلك المستشفيات.  المستشفيات، وذلك
بالطبع حيث أن القطاع الصحي في غزة
يتعرض بالفعل
لضغوط هائلة حيث اضطر عدد من المستشفيات
بالفعل إلى إغلاق أو إغلاق
أقسام مختلفة، الأمر الذي
وضع ضغطًا أكبر على
النظام الصحي هناك والقدرة على
علاج أه غزة و  المدنيين هناك
والفلسطينيين يأتي هذا في الوقت الذي
أفادت فيه وزارة الصحة في غزة التي تديرها حماس وفي الضفة الغربية أن
عدد القتلى الآن (عدد
الفلسطينيين الذين قتلوا هنا) قد تجاوز
11000، بما في ذلك 4500 طفل و
3000 امرأة، وهو ما ربما يكون جزءًا مما
أجبر وزير الخارجية على  قال وزير الخارجية أنتوني
بلينكين أنه يجب عمل المزيد
هنا، والمعاناة من جانب
الفلسطينيين، كما يقول، هائلة في
هذه الأثناء كما أشرت إلى
الممر الإنساني الذي سمح الجيش الإسرائيلي
بإغلاقه منذ لحظات قليلة
وشاهدنا الصور تخرج من صلاح الدين
شارع في غزة، وهو أحد الشوارع الرئيسية في الشمال
والجنوب كارتر، يبدو أن آلافًا آخرين
سيُخلون اليوم وسننتظر
رقمًا رسميًا ولكن هذا بالإضافة إلى
عشرات الآلاف بالأمس وعشرات
الآلاف في اليوم السابق لمحاولة
الخروج من شمال غزة حيث كان جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي  لقد
ركزوا الكثير من جهودهم هناك وقد
رأينا نتائج هذا
التدمير حيث يحاول جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي تدمير
حماس وملاحقة بنيتها التحتية تحت الأرض.
كيت نعم والكثير من
الناس يستغلون ذلك كما
نشاهد فيديو هنا لعمليات الإخلاء هذه
نوافذ للخروج سيرًا على الأقدام بالعربة كما
ترون في مقاطع الفيديو التي
نشاهدها قادمة منذ أيام، شكرًا لك
أو شكرًا جزيلاً لك أورين